hey guys today we're gonna be use the
foot as a way of diagnosing the liver
and of course my disclaimer here is that
you're not really diagnosing a liver
disease you have to go to the doctor and
have them do tests to figure that out
but this will give you some good clues
on a potential problem with your liver
okay that being said let's dive in and
these are just little indicators that
can actually help you narrow things down
the first thing we're going to talk
about is the little red and brown dots
they can be larger and smaller and you
can also have like little shininess to
them they're usually on the lower leg
that is poor circulation and that is
usually a liver problem it could also be
diabetes it could be many other things
but you see this a lot when people have
liver problems so the actual appearance
of the lower leg and the foot gives a
lot of great information about the
overall health of the person because the
heart has to send blood all the way down
to your feet and then back through the
vascular system and usually if there's a
liver problem or a heart problem
whatever there's gonna be a vascular
problem and you're gonna see it in this
part of your body a lot because the poor
circulation that's occurring so a lot of
these problems happen at a the greatest
distance from the heart and also even
with diabetes for example you see
neurological problems in your feet in
your hands because of that fact because
it affects the distal fingers which is
the the point furthest away from the
heart okay so you'll see red and brown
little discoloration type specks on the
lower leg and then something called
spider veins or another name would be
spider nevus which usually see this in
cirrhosis and what's happening to the
liver is you're building up a lot of
estrogen and too much estrogen can
affect the vascular system so you can
see varicose veins and spider veins and
you can see them in the lower legs then
we have cracked heels okay this is
usually a vitamin b3 deficiency or an
omega-3 fatty acid deficiency why
because one of the functions of the
liver is to make bile and help you
absorb these fatty acids not just
omega-3 fatty acids but vitamin A which
could be involved in the skin vitamin E
which could be involved in the skin
those are fat soluble vitamins but
vitamin b3 also affects the skin other B
vitamins also can affect the skin as
well just how they relate to the
cofactor the to help the enzymes work
especially with proteins so b3
deficiency can create a problem another
name for that would be pellagra people
with pellagra which is a B 3 deficiency
have a lot of skin issues all right each
of the foot usually in the bottom of the
foot that is a backup of fluids into the
liver it's a congested liver
it could be bio backing up and you're
getting a buildup of histamines a
congested liver so you could have
itching in the foot also you can have
pain or inflammation in the bottom of
the foot a lot of times people associate
that with something called plantar
fasciitis where it's really not quite a
fasciitis it's just a liver problem and
then you also have hot feet hot feet is
another symptom of a bad liver and then
we have bad odor so you have smelly feet
why because the liver is not able to
detoxify correctly and it's backing up
through the skin usually it delivers bad
the person's diet is pretty bad and the
entire body is backed up with garbage
and especially the large intestine and
the kidneys and it's coming out through
the skin so you can't just have a really
terrible unhealthy bad liver and have a
very healthy kidney or colon there if
one is bad they're usually
all pretty congested and unhealthy okay
pitting edema that's where you press
your finger into the lower leg and it
leaves a dent and it just stays there
that's fluid back up that's a common
liver symptom and then we have fungus
toenail fungus people with liver
problems have a higher level of fungus
growing on their body because they're
they're usually have an imbalance in the
micro flora and the gut and that is
going to relate to an overgrowth of
fungus and yeast and the outside of the
body so that's why you see like dandruff
and psoriasis toenail fungus and then
the the nail bed in it you can actually
happen on the hands or the
feet the nail bed is going to be white
you're gonna usually lose that little
moon shape thing Luna down here so it's
going to be white because of the poor
circulation that's occurring on that now
bad alright so then the next question is
what really causes liver problems a lot
of things one big one is the side effect
from medications another one is a lot of
sugar in the diet especially high
fructose corn syrup cooked foods so if
you're just having canned foods which
are pasteurized and you're not having
anything raw that's eventually going to
be very very hard on the liver and the
kidney and also a lack of any vegetables
and if you're eating junk food combined
with that you have no enzymes to put in
the body
no antioxidants from these vegetables so
that can be a problem excessive alcohol
that's a given
and then excessive protein so if you're
doing massive amounts of protein it
built up a lot of nitrogen waste over
time that can then overload the liver
and the kidney and put a lot of stress
on and so if there is liver damage or
kidney damage you want to go a little
lower on the protein higher in the
vegetables okay so now what is a good
diet for the liver
now if you're new to my channel click
the link down below I will show you a
combination of a healthy ketogenic diet
and intimate fasting okay so that's why
I'm gonna recommend for those of you
that are not new and you've been on my
channel if you watch a lot of videos you
already know this you're on the program
you're already getting great success so
go ahead and put your comments down
below so the new people can see that
this that really does work alright
thanks for watching
if you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos